MEETING THAT YOU PROBABLY
WOULDN'T BE OUR LAST MEETING
HERE WE ARE AGAIN WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE STATE
SENATE COMMITTEE AND ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR TWO BILLS
TODAY. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX
WHICH WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
SO WILL NOT BE CONSIDERED
TODAY. WE'RE GONNA HERE A. B.
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN. AND A. B.
NINE THIRTY SIX WHILE WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE'LL START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE
COMMUNITY HEAR TESTIMONY ON A.
B. FIFTEEN THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AS YOU AS YOU WISH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
ARE WITH ONE EXCEPTION ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN THIRTEEN IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD CODE CLEANUP
BILL CAN MAKE SEVERAL CLEAR
FINE AND TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
VARIOUS SECTIONS OF THE CODES.
FIXES DATES ND CORRECT
GRAMMAR. ONE SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENT IS INCLUDED A TO AB
TEN FIFTY FOUR CODIFIED EARLIER
THIS SUMMER WHICH AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS ESTABLISH THE
WILDFIRE FIND. OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE TREASURY. THE REVENUES
FROM THE FUND COME FROM
RATEPAYERS AN ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS CONTRIBUTIONS TO
PAY ELIGIBLE CLAIMS ARISING
FROM CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN
THE EVENT THAT THE FUND
TERMINATES A. B. TEN FIFTY FOUR
REQUIRES THAT ANY REMAINING
FUNDS BE REBATED DIRECTLY. TO
THE RATE PAYERS. TAX COUNSEL
HAS ADVISED THAT THE
RQUIREMENT TO RETURN ANY
REMAINING FUNDS TO RATE PAYERS
JEOPARDIZES THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO OBTAIN A PRIVATE LETTER
RULING FROM THE IRS THAT THE
FUND IS ENTITLED TO TAX EXEMPT
STATUS. THIS WOULD RESULT IN
THE WALL FIRE FUND ITSELF BEING
SUBJECT TO FEDERAL INCOME TAX
WHICH WOULD BE A TERRIBLE
RESULT. BOTH INITIAL AND
ONGOING CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
FUND IN ANY INVESTMENT EARNINGS
OF THE FUND WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
TWENTY ONE PERCENT. FEDERAL
INCOME TAX INSURED A TRANSFER
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM THE
WELFARE FUND TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT WOULD UNDERMINE
THE LONG TERM DURABILITY OF THE
FUN AB FIFTEEN THIRTEEN
ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM BY
TRANSFERRING THE FUNDS THE
GENERAL FUND. WITH THE INTENT
THAT IT WILL BE USED FOR WHILE
FAR MEDICATIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. VERY WELL
CLERK WE HAVE A QUORUM PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HUESO PRESENT
HUESO PRESENT MOORLACH BRADFORD.
AFTER PRESENT CHIANG CHAIN HERE
DODD DIED HERE HERTZBERG HILL
HILL HERE MCGUIRE RUBIO RUBIO
HERE SKINNER STERN. STERN
HERE'S DOWN WIENER. MOORLACH
PRESENT. VERY WELL WE HAVE A
QUORUM OF WE'RE NOW ACCEPTING
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC
ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE OR
OPPOSITION ANYBODY HERE TO
SPEAK ON THIS MEASURE AT ALL.
FROM THE PUBLIC. ALL RIGHT VERY
WELL COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY
COMMENTS. SURE STERN THERE
STERN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY MIGHT MY QUESTION IS
MORE ABOUT ACTUALLY THE PACE
CITED THE BILL WHICH I KNOW. IS
MORE TECHNICAL IN NATURE THE
UPDATED REFERENCES I DID THERE
IS THERE IS. THERE ARE
OUTSTANDING FUNDS THAT HAVE
BEEN. STOCK PILED IN THAT
ACCOUNT AND NOT EXPENDED I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE WHERE THIS
ISSUE BUT THERE BEEN SOME IN
SOME CASE WHERE THE PACE LOANS
OF GONE WRONG THERE'S SOME
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE STILL BEING
WAIT. WAITING TO BE MADE WHOLE
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. THIS
BILL DOESN'T TOUCH THAT FUNDED
IT JUST TOUCH THE IT IT ONLY
TOUCHES THE- OUTSTANDING FUNDS
FROM THE FROM THE ON THE WILD
FIRE SIDE THAT'S CORRECT OKAY.
SO DOES IT AT YOUR DOES IT
ADDRESS ANY OF THOSE ISSUES I
JUST MENTION ON THOSE TECHNICAL
ITEMS AROUND PACE IN TERMS OF
JUST BEING ABLE TO TRY TO MAKE
THOSE HOMEOWNERS HOLDER REGION
THE NO THE ONLY SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGE OTHER ASPECTS OF THE
CHANGES AS REFERENCE WOULD BE
PURELY TECHNICAL ARE.
GRAMMATICAL. THE ONE THAT IS
MORE SENSITIVE AND THAT'S WHY I
WOULD PROBABLY THE REASON WHY
WE'RE HERE IN THE COMMITTED
THIS TODAY. IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF THERE'S ANYTHING LEFT
IN THE FUN AT THE END THAT IT
GOES IN THE DIRECTION OF THE
GENERAL FUND AS OPPOSED TO
BEING SUBJECT TO FEDERAL TAX.
UNDERSTOOD OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY
ANYONE ELSE WE HAVE A MOTION
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TEN
TO TWENTY NINE TEN. BE THAT THE
MEASURE BE RETURNED TO THE
SENATE FOR CONSIDERATION HUESO
I WAS SO I MOORLACH. MORE LIKE
I BRADFORD BRADFORD I CHING
CHANG AYE DODD DODD AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HILL AYE
MCGUIRE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
SKINNER STERN STERN ICE DOWN
WIENER. THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
ROLE OF CONSTRUCTION MEMBERS.
NOW WE'RE HEARING IN A. B. NINE
THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS. ASSEMBLYMEMBER WELCOME.
SEVEN BE SURE YOU GUYS.
ALLOWING US HERE BECAUSE
INTEL'S. GUYS AND GALS YEAH ALL
EVERYBODY SO I. WITH THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL AND SO THESE LATEST ROUND
OF AMENDMENTS AS A RESULT OF
WORK THAT TO OUR OFFICES HAD
WITH WITH OSCAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
WITH NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS IT'S BEEN
A LONG PROCESS I LIKE TO THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION STAKEHOLDERS
FOR WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE
THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR TO GET
THIS LEGISLATION TO WHERE IT IS
NOW SIR. THE STRONGER BUILDING
ON FIRE STARTED. HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL MOVE ALL REGISTERED
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I WITH
ACCEPTED PARTNER FINANCE BUT IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT THEY HAVE
NOT. YET ANALYZE THE MOST
RECENT VERSION OF THE BILL. AND
SO CERTAINLY THIS IS A BILL
THAT ENHANCES OIL
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY IN OUR
STATE. MY FIRST MAKING SURE
THAT WE DEFINE IT NON FLOATING
OIL AND STATUTES. THE SECOND TO
ENSURE THAT SAFETY STANDARDS
ARE REGULARLY UPDATED TO
INCORPORATE THE BEST POSSIBLE
TOOLS FOR CLEANUP. OF NON FOR
AN OIL. AND THIRD IT ENHANCES
THE COLLECTION OF INFORMATION
ON ON FOREIGN OIL. MOVING
CALIFORNIA BY REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
ELECTED PUSH SUCH DATA THAT.
THAT IT CONCERNS THE MOVEMENTS
OF GOOGLE OF CRUDE BY RAIL CAR
AND BY VESSEL. AND SO CERTAINLY
THERE IS NO DENYING THAT MORE
MORE HEAVY CRUDES ARE MAKING
THEIR WAY TO CALIFORNIA.
TRANSPORTED BY WAY OF TRAINS IN
OIL TANKERS AND SO WHAT THIS
BILL IS YOU KNOW HAS ALWAYS
BEEN ABOUT HIS ABOUT SAFETY AND
PREPAREDNESS. AND SO CERTAINLY
I YOU KNOW AGAIN THIS BILL IT
MANDATES AN UPDATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS THE CONTINGENCY
PLANNING IN OUR STATE. TO
ENSURE THAT OSCARS ADEQUATELY
PREPARED TO DEAL WITH SPILLS OF
THESE NON FLOATING OILS SHOULD
THEY OCCUR. THESE ARE OILS MOST
LIKELY TO CAUSE LASTING LASTING
DAMAGE TO OUR MARINE
ENVIRONMENT OUR WATERWAYS AND
TO OUR PUBLIC HEALTH. AND SO
WITH THAT MR SURELY IS A YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY AND I RESPECT
THE ASPIRIN I'VE THANK YOU YOU
HAVE A SPEAKER HERE. ASKED
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I VICTORIA ROME WITH
NOT RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
BILL WITH MISTER REED YES AND-
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY KEEPER.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA TAKE THE NECESSARY
STEPS TO PREPARE FORCE BILL OF
THIS NEWER. OF OIL THAT IS
INCREASINGLY COMING INTO OUR
STATE. IN CASE IT'S NOT OBVIOUS
IF WE WERE TO EXPERIENCE A
SPILL OR AN ACCIDENT OFF THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA. AND OIL
SANK WITHIN A MATTER OF HOURS
THAT WOULD BE DEVASTATING TO
OUR COAST TO OUR WILDLIFE AND
TORE FISHING AND RECREATION
BUSINESSES. SO A. B. NINE
THIRTY SIX JUST HELPS TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S PREPARED. FOR
AN EVENT OF THE SORT WHICH WE
HOPE NEVER HAPPENS. THANK YOU
FOR TO THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED THE BILL PREVIOUSLY
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY WITH
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS OUT THERE
WOULD LIKE TO. ADD ON TO THE-
THIS CONVERSATION SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. THE PRICE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
CONSERVATION VOTERS
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND A
NEXT GEN. ERICA MARTINEZ WITH
EARTH JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
LAUREN COMMERCE HERE CALL
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MR
MEMBERS DON MEDI WITH BNSF
RAILWAY WE HAD VERY GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSOR
AND WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS
OFFICE AND WE WILL WORK OUT
SOME TECHNICAL CHANGES OR
PLEASE TO NOT HAVE TO OPPOSE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY DISCUSSION
ANYONE CENTER WINNER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR PERSONA CAN
GRADUALLY THE AUTHOR I AUTHORS
WILL GO A COUPLE YEARS AGO WAS
UNABLE TO MOVE IT OUT OF THE
FIRST HOUSE SO IS NOW THE
SECOND BILL OR YOU SUCCEED OR I
HAVE FAILED SO CONGRATULATIONS
BUT I SERIOUSLY THIS IS A
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT BILL
BECAUSE AS IS ROSA START
STATED. THIS IS JUST VERY
SERIOUS OF THE STUFF ARTS
THINKING. INTO OUR WATER WAYS.
WITH THE FIVE DEVASTATING AND
THERE ARE. THEY'RE GONNA CLOSE
RULE OKAY. SORRY IT'S OKAY
THERE OR ENOUGH REGULATIONS IN
PLACE ARE ENOUGH CONTROLS IN
PLACE AND THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN THIS DIRECTION SO I'M
HAPPY TO. I SUPPORT THE BILL.
SIR MORE LOOK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST HAVE ONE QUICK
QUESTION THAT IS. DO WE DO WE
HAVE AN INCIDENT THAT I COULD
LOOK UP WHERE WE HAD A- A MAJOR
CASE OF. NON POLLUTING OIL AND
THIS BILL IN THE DAMAGE AND THE
FOLLOW UP. SURE SO THE ONE CASE
THAT WE CAN POINT TO WAS A
SPILL. IN THE BELIEVES IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN. IN THE STATE
OF MICHIGAN IT WAS A SPELL IT
TO THE KALAMAZOO RIVER. WHICH
RESULTED FROM A I WANT TO SAY A
BUSTED PIPELINE. AND THE RESULT
WAS YEARS AND YEARS OF CLEAN UP
EFFORTS. OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
IN DAMAGES DONE AND CERTAINLY
THE CLEAN UP WAS YOU KNOW NOT
EFFECTIVE. AND THERE'S LASTING
ISSUES TO THIS DAY IT'S BEEN
WELL DOCUMENTED AND SO
CERTAINLY MY OFFICE COULD
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR STAFF IF
YOU LIKE ALL THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. WE HAVE A
MOTION. THE MOTION OF HUNDREDS
TURN OF HENRY MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS. THIS IS BETH
ASPEN EITHER OKAY THANK YOU
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PERCENT TO TWENTY NINE POINT
CAN BE THAT THE MEASURE VERY TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION WESSEL I WAS SO I
AM A LOT. MORE LIKE AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CHING.
CHANG AYE DODD. BURKE HERTZBERG
AYE HILL HILL AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SKINNER. STERN STERN AYE STONE
STONE NO WIENER WIENER HIGH. NO
ONE. OKAY YOU HAVE AN OPPOSED
TO GET OUT WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE
ROLE OF CONTRAPTION MEMBERS OF
QUEEN CALL UPS MEMBERS OF. ON
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO AB
FIFTY THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN QUICK
PLESE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CURRENT PHONE EIGHT ZERO
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER
DOWN AYE STONE AYE WIENER
WIENER AYE. IF WE GET YOU ON
THE OKAY WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO NINE THIRTY
SIX NINE THIRTY SIX CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CURRENT TEN ONE DIED DIED I
SKINNER. ISSUE ON OUR WAY
SKINNER HAVE
. PLASTICS
RECYCLING AND I'M HOPING ON IT
YEAH SO HAS ANYBODY PREPARED
OUT LIKE A- SIDE BY SIDE
.
THIRTY SIX. NINE THIRTY SIX
CURRENT BUT ELEVEN ONE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE. ARE YOU CALLING
FROM. ON A. B. FIFTEEN THIRTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE ZERO
SKINNER. SKINNER I. VERY WELL
BILLS ARE OUT WERE WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY MUCH